foreign  here I thought we were special fellas  this here's Bag Man hang man whatever  the hook on the mission is this  [Music]  everyone here is the best there is  who the hell are they going to get to  teach us  Captain Pete Maverick Mitchell let me be  perfectly blocked you are not my first  choice you were here at the request of  Admiral kazanski AKA Iceman he seems to  think that you have something left to  offer the Navy  what that is I can't imagine  it's all due respect sir I'm not a  teacher  just want to manage the expectations  what the hell  good morning aviators  this is your captain speaking  and we're off  here we are intrigued  we're going into combat on a level no  living Pilots ever seen not even him  you think up there you're dead believe  me  my dad believed in you  I'm not gonna make the same mistake  [Music]  anything happens to them  you'll never forgive yourself  [Music]  no turning back now come on  [Music]  having any fun yet  [Music]  foreign